okay i am sitting here with 2006 olympic
gold medal winner ted liggetty hey
nice to meet you man nice to meet you
too it's an olympic handshake would be
really disappointing if you just gave me
a dead fish i understand you dressed
yourself my girlfriend actually has a
lot of sand how i dress is that right i
would normally dress in sweatpants every
day yeah
dad if there were no women it would just
be a bunch of dudes walking around in
sweatpants and flip-flops and would nail
it exactly
you have gold medals one olympic one i
have multiple world championship ones
right don't you feel like medals should
be m-e-t-a-l-s
that might make sense actually wouldn't
you rather win a metal
oh there's ted with his metal
you do do a lot of drugs
nope
a little i got drug tested this morning
so i can't is it do they watch you pee
they do they do you pull your pants down
right below your butt crack and then you
pull your shirt up to your belly button
and then they you kick it all out wait
no
facing they gotta like look at it and
everything yeah coming out coming out to
make sure you're not yeah getting in
someone else's like mine which is
available for 35
when i was at world juniors they
actually made me look or they wanted to
look underneath you know to make sure
there was like not a tube or something
there
did someone do that it's it's true story
huh whoever did that should get a gold
medal in shenaniganz yep
ted leggetty man
teddy thanks ready thanks so much for
doing it you're a pleasure it's fun i
wish you the best of luck thank you all
right